so you're asking what is the spin number
quantum number and how can it be less
than one well the spin refers to the
rotation of an elementary particle a
particle like the electron spins has a
spin much like the earth thousand
angular momentum and although in
classical physics that angular momentum
that rotation that spin can be anything
it's continuous number in quantum
mechanics it's quantized many things in
quantum mechanics are quantized that's
why we called quantum mechanics they can
only assume take discrete values and in
particular the rotation of objects can
only take discrete values which are half
integer multiples of Planck's constant
Planck's constant is has dimensions of a
angular momentum of a rotation the
magnitude of rotation and so the spin of
any elementary particle must be a
multiple of a half integer multiple 1/2
1/3 amps to five halves 3 and so on of
this fundamental unit of rotation
Planck's constant the electron in the
fact turns out to have the lowest
possible nonzero rotation of 1/2
Planck's constant perfectly possible in
fact the consequence of the quantization
laws of angular momentum which were one
of the important clues that led to the
development of quantum mechanics